hi Dina welcome to et Canada hello how's
it going um it's well we haven't started
yet but we've been sequestered to a
hotel room yeah
and it's it's so quiet I'm a single mom
you know so you have drama Dina and I
always have things going on or dogs or
my mom calling here it's so quiet I'm
like what do I do
dragging all the PAS and hang out with
me cuz I don't know to talk to
it's a Big Brother Celebrity Big Brother
yeah what made you want to do Celebrity
Big Brother um I'm kind of empty nesting
right now I do manage my two younger
children the mountain but I think it's I
just want to have fun and I love game
shows yes I watched the celebrity one
and I was I was hooked
you're hooked on is pretty cool yeah
you're a famous for being Lindsay
Lohan's mom oh you better manage its
I've been in the business even before I
had kids yeah dancer so you know
Broadway instead of New York
but so I this is kind of I've always
been doing this and and my kids just
loved it so I have four yeah okay I did
in the day they're all Ford models but I
was with Katie Ford so I it just says
normal to me I said if I were an
attorney you'd all be attorneys you know
that's that's how I roll how does
Lindsay feel about you going on Big
Brother she at first she thought it was
the London one okay I was offered a long
time ago and that's a little bit
different yeah then here I feel safe and
she's she packed for me wrote me a list
of what to do and what not to do and she
packed a lot on her don't list what did
she say don't do she don't trust anyone
no I didn't say anything doing it if she
basically just told me silence is golden
like just learn about the people you
yeah kind of stay slow and steady
you know what traits do you have that
you've been a mom a momager he's been in
this press you've been you you've done
it all what skills will you take from
learning all of that to dealing with
these people in the Big Brother house I
mean I'm going in this kind of
of the house like I that's what I know
I'm clean I'll cook I'm hoping there's a
celebrity chef involved because that
would be awesome
really well but um yeah I'm not really
I'm not really an antagonistic person I
mean it's funny because I've always had
to protect my children obviously from
people being mean but now it's just be
so I'm not really mean I didn't like
moms or like mama bear when it comes to
their children but we're a little bit
more yeah but when it comes to yourself
you tend to neglect caring for yourself
a lot you might lose yourself a little
bit yeah you know so and and now that my
kids aren't my youngest is 22 pumps so
he's a model time gene and actor as well
and a Leanne is a singer is recording
just song and you add new years and I
just feel like it's my turn
yeah - just breathe a little bit for
sure possibly so you don't know why fig
this show hopefully I can breathe so you
mentioned that you saw the previous
celebrity version or bits of it um yeah
and they have tapes that were I'm
watching okay
I liked it who did you like the previous
season um I like them all um well you're
such a mom and I forget some of their
names that's why I'm a little that's
okay oh that one okay Marisa ate yeah I
thought the basketball player was an
angel sweetheart but you won't meet his
wife but you won't do that row and
they're gonna stay up from Chittagong
nurse her baby yeah I understood that I
don't like they flake all the people who
left I already miss alarming babies and
the people that you're like you know
nobody late oh yeah I mean she won't you
know she's in hairspray so I love her
yeah yeah she was the most unlikely to
win and she she won yes which is great
because it gives Lady sweet I think what
is your strategy going in I'm just gonna
kind of get to know them first and then
I'll figure out what theirs is are their
personalities that you just won't jive
with I don't know him mentally in your
personal life what personalities or just
off-putting I'm not really a fan of mean
people mm-hmm so no mean the mean girl
Mean Girls want to play the Mean Girls
like you know what it's a ly comes out I
want to help you out a little bit cuz
you're so nice
and I played this game before oh you did
I did and I feel like you're watching
you're brushing up and you're going into
this um do you know the lingo of Big
Brother cuz I played this game last year
veto veto is that a good thing house
I think vetoes great to have yes and I
would rather be take a veto than be the
house the head of house yes yeah because
you can use that to save yourself right
I think I have to go read them I have to
go study
what about backdoor you know what it's
not a good thing and it's not a good
thing and I don't want factorize get
kicked off my follow the rules no oh I
don't know what that is you know what
after your job unless you know after
we're done wrapping okay I know where
you were your alliances so you from
watching you know do you know I'm hoping
I know they had a list out that said
people may be on it so you realized were
you yeah I was on it and I'm here so
maybe that's it has some validity toward
it but I think I hope that because then
I'll feel like I can't have an alliance
you guys hear that Dina was out on
Twitter reading all I wanted but I never
said anything I don't know people
finding them know for sure for sure for
sure it's really hard to hide things you
know we get on an airplane and the girl
the desk is calling someone you know
yeah
what competitions do you think you'll do
great and there's physical lines there's
mental ones and there's also social a
sheep so hopefully I'll navigate that I
think the fun ones wearing silly
costumes like whatever
yeah I'm just gonna roll with it it's
gonna be hilarious I mean I just want to
see that they are yeah I think you're
gonna have fun yeah I think I'm a little
nervous more about that than the
strategic ones you're nervous about the
competitions more I just want to know
what they are what we have to do we
don't know everything don't you
yeah you ever heard their motto is
expect the unexpected
they don't want you knowing nothing no
oh wow I figured that out well I'm here
but but it's okay let's roll it